we're gonna begin with this in Louisiana
police are hunting for suspects in the
murder of a beloved local civil rights
activist the East Baton Rouge coroner
yesterday ruled the death of Sadie
Roberts Joseph a homicide
she died of suffocation the 75 year old
body was found in the trunk of her car
four days ago
Erol Burnett is in Baton Rouge at the
Museum robert's Joseph found it almost
two decades ago
Erol good morning what's the latest on
this case good morning just to give you
a sense of how sacred Sadie Roberts
Joseph is a state lawmaker is collecting
donations right now to keep her museum
open you see the main structure behind
me this trolley a part of it as well her
body was discovered about two miles from
here and medical examiner's are looking
at it closely to try and understand what
happened to her in her final hours on
Friday
investigators say community activist
Sadie roberts Joseph died from traumatic
asphyxia including suffocation not long
after she visited her family CBS News
spoke with Pat McAlister ladakh anis she
can't go down like this she don't
deserve this
Roberts Joseph's family says the 75 year
old stopped by her sister's house Friday
to bake a southern staple corn bread
just hours later her body was found
inside her own vehicle's trunk in a
residential neighborhood police now
looking for potential witnesses to that
crime the fact that somebody would even
do this to her it's it's disturbing it
really is she made everybody feel good
about
to let you know that you can carry on
and we want to miss that
her brother described Robert Joseph as
selfless she would always do a favor for
people they were never too much to do
but he says she was best known for her
local contributions she began her
african-american museum in 2001 it
includes artwork and historic items like
this bus for the 1953 Baton Rouge bus
boycotts
this video shows Roberts Joseph at this
year's annual Juneteenth celebration
when she hosted four years in Baton
Rouge to commemorate the emancipation of
slaves in the south news of Roberts
Joseph's death has rocked this community
she was passionate about preserving this
museum and keeping it here for
generations to come and enjoy her impact
on this city it's hard to put into words
but I do think Baton Rouge owes it to
her to make certain that this legacy of
hers remains the police are remaining
very tight-lipped they cite this ongoing
investigation the city is offering
$5,000 to information leading to an
arrest or an indictment and consider
this the family is fearful that if a
suspect is announced but not in custody
the community may seek its own justice
and tarika there is a vigil here tonight
Wow err oh thank you what a beautiful
spirit she was